aquí tengo un cohete y ese cohete va a
lanzar un proyectil no sea un tipo de
roca con una velocidad de 10 metros por
segundo y la dirección de esta velocidad
será de 30 grados por encima del
horizonte o el ángulo entre la dirección
de la velocidad y la horizontal es de 30
grados lo que queremos hacer en este
vídeo es encontrar qué tan lejos llega
esta roca qué tan lejos
llegará
y para simplificar este problema lo que
vamos a hacer es descomponer este vector
en sus elementos horizontal y vertical
por ejemplo su componente vertical al
descomponer este vector velocidad estará
aquí
y su componente horizontal estará aquí
así que tendremos cierta cantidad de
velocidad o el componente vertical de la
velocidad hacia arriba y lo podremos
usar para saber qué tanto tiempo estuvo
este objeto en el aire porque sin
importar cuál es su componente
horizontal es el componente vertical el
que nos va a indicar qué tan rápido se
desacelera y vuelve a acelerar para caer
al suelo y así nos dirá qué tanto tiempo
estuvo el objeto en el aire y ya que
encontramos que tanto tiempo estuvo en
el aire no podremos multiplicar por el
componente horizontal de la velocidad
para encontrar qué tan lejos llegó
nuevamente aquí suponemos que la
resistencia del aire es cero si hubiera
una resistencia al aire significativa
este componente horizontal no se
mantendría constante mientras está en el
aire pero suponiendo que no cambia esto
supondrá mos que la resistencia del aire
es cero podríamos imaginarnos que este
experimento ocurre en la luna si
queremos ser muy apegados a la realidad
resolvamos el problema lo primero que
queremos hacer es descomponer este
vector velocidad que tiene una magnitud
de 10
por segundo y tiene un ángulo de 30
grados con respecto a la horizontal
vamos a descomponerlo en sus elementos
xy
su componente horizontal
y su componente vertical encontremos
primero el componente vertical como
podemos encontrar esto si conocemos este
ángulo sabemos que esto es un ángulo
recto así que es un triángulo rectángulo
y conocemos la hipotenusa así que este
lado que nos interesa es el lado opuesto
al ángulo como podemos encontrar la
magnitud o la longitud de este vector
vertical pues bueno vamos a usar
nuestras funciones trigonométricas
nuevamente escribimos aquí nuestro
zocato a sol
acá
y todas aquí nos indica que el seno es
igual al cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa el cose no es igual al cateto
adyacente entre la hipotenusa y la
tangente es igual al cate todo puesto
entre el adyacente y aquí el seno es el
opuesto entre la hipotenusa este es el
opuesto y conocemos la hipotenusa así
que el seno de 30 grados va a ser igual
a la magnitud de este lado opuesto la
magnitud del componente vertical de la
velocidad de y esta es la dirección
vertical la del eje y así que esto va a
ser igual a la magnitud de nuestra
velocidad vertical hacia arriba dividido
entre la magnitud de nuestro vector
velocidad que es nuestra hipotenusa y
está sabemos que es de 10 metros por
segundo y para encontrar este término lo
que vamos a hacer es multiplicar ambos
lados de esta ecuación por 10 nos va a
quedar lo escribo aquí
por seno de 30 grados igual a la
magnitud de nuestra velocidad vertical y
cuál es el seno de 30 grados quizá
ustedes memorizaron esto de su clase de
trigonometría básica y pueden también
sacar su calculadora para encontrarlo
pero el seno de 30 grados es bastante
directo es un medio así que el seno de
30 grados pueden sacar la calculadora y
encontrarlos si no me creen o no se
acuerdan y apenas ahorita lo están
recordando es igual a un medio así que
vi es por un medio va a ser igual a 5 y
se me estaban olvidando poner las
unidades 5 metros por segundo va a ser
igual a la magnitud de nuestro
componente vertical y esto para qué nos
sirve bueno este proyectil su componente
vertical es de 5 metros por segundo y va
a permanecer en el aire la misma
cantidad de tiempo que lo haría
cualquier otro objeto que tenga un
componente vertical de 5 metros por
segundo si lanzáramos hacia arriba
alguna roca o proyectil a 5 metros por
segundo esa roca o proyectil permanece
en el aire la misma cantidad de tiempo
que lo hará este proyectil de acá porque
tienen el mismo componente vertical
pensemos cuánto tiempo va a permanecer
en el aire partiendo de este ejemplo en
donde comenzamos a nivel del suelo y
terminamos también a nivel del suelo en
la misma elevación y suponiendo que la
resistencia al aire es cero podemos
hacer una pequeña simplificación acá y
veremos más adelante una versión un
poquito más complicada para que se pueda
aplicar a más situaciones bueno aquí
podemos pensar cuál es nuestro cambio de
velocidad aquí si vemos solo la
velocidad vertical bueno veamos todo lo
que tiene que ver con el componente
vertical en azul vamos a ver todo lo
vertical aquí nuestra velocidad inicial
en el componente vertical va a ser igual
a 5 metros por segundo y vamos a usar la
convención de que todo lo que va hacia
arriba va a ser positivo
y todo lo que va hacia abajo va a ser
negativo bueno vamos a comenzar con
cierta velocidad vamos a estar
desacelerando nos detendremos un momento
en el aire y después iremos acelerando
cada vez más debido a la aceleración de
la gravedad hasta que demos contra el
suelo y si suponemos que la resistencia
al aire es cero cuando regresemos aquí
al suelo tendremos la misma magnitud de
la velocidad pero iremos en otra
dirección en la dirección contraria
así que nuestra velocidad final y
estamos hablando aquí exclusivamente del
componente vertical va a ser igual
recordemos estamos analizando este
componente vertical para encontrar el
tiempo que tarda este objeto en el aire
así que nuestra velocidad final va a ser
igual a menos 5 metros por segundo ya
que la dirección de este vector va hacia
abajo y esto lo que representa la
cantidad negativa si esta es la
velocidad inicial la velocidad final se
verá así la misma magnitud sólo que en
la dirección opuesta así que cuál va a
ser el cambio en velocidad en nuestra
dirección vertical
en la dirección de iu va a ser igual a
nuestra velocidad final de menos 5
metros por segundo menos nuestra
velocidad inicial que es de 5 metros por
segundo que va a ser igual a menos 10
metros por segundo como nos sirve esta
información para calcular cuánto tiempo
estuvo el objeto en el aire bueno porque
sabemos que nuestro cambio de velocidad
vertical es igual a nuestra aceleración
de la gravedad en la dirección vertical
multiplicada por el cambio en el tiempo
la cantidad de tiempo que transcurre en
todo este trayecto cual es la
aceleración en nuestra dirección
vertical pues es la aceleración
provocada por la fuerza de gravedad que
tiene un objeto en caída libre por lo
que esto de aquí va a ser igual a menos
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado esta
cantidad de aquí es menos 10 metros por
segundo lo acabamos de calcular así que
este va a ser nuestro cambio en
velocidad menos 10 metros por segundo
igual a la aceleración vertical que es
menos 9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
recordemos que este símbolo indica la
dirección del vector y esto lo
multiplicamos por el cambio en el tiempo
como eso es lo que queremos encontrar
vamos a dividir ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre menos 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado así que aquí esto va
a estar dividido entre menos 9.8 metros
por segundo al cuadrado
esto también menos 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado estos se cancelan y
aquí me queda el cambio en el tiempo que
es menos 10 metros por segundo entre
menos 9.8 metros por segundo menos entre
menos es igual a más y ahora saco mi
calculadora para encontrar este valor y
está bien que el cambio en el tiempo sea
positivo ya que queremos un tiempo que
avance no que retroceda y aquí también
suponemos que el transcurso del tiempo
es positivo saco mi calculadora y esto
es lo mismo que tener 10 entre 9.8 y nos
da 1.0 204 y vamos a redondear lo a dos
dígitos aquí lo que me da 1.0 dos
segundos así que esto de aquí es igual a
1.02
segundos así que me cambio en el tiempo
bueno aquí estoy usando una minúscula
pero bueno no importa aquí también puedo
poner minúsculas nuestro cambio en el
tiempo es igual a 1.02 segundos y ahora
como vamos a usar esta información para
saber qué tan lejos llegó este objeto
cuando cayó de nuevo al suelo suponiendo
que mantiene su componente horizontal
sin cambios durante todo este tiempo
podemos multiplicar esto por nuestro
cambio en el tiempo y obtendremos el
desplazamiento total en la dirección
horizontal para hacerlo tenemos que
encontrar el valor de este componente
horizontal que aún no lo hemos hecho así
que esta es la magnitud de nuestro
componente horizontal de la velocidad o
en la dirección de x nuevamente vemos
nuestras funciones trigonométricas y ya
que este lado es adyacente al ángulo el
adyacente entre la hipotenusa es el
coseno el co seno de un ángulo es igual
al cateto adyacente entre la hipotenusa
así que tenemos que el coseno
de 30 grados es igual al lado adyacente
que es este componente horizontal de x
entre la hipotenusa que es 10 metros por
segundo
multiplicamos ambos lados por 10 metros
por segundo nos quedará que la magnitud
de nuestro componente horizontal o
nuestro componente en x va a ser igual a
10 metros por segundo por el coseno de
30 grados quizá ustedes no recuerden
cuales el coseno de 30 grados pueden
usar la calculadora para esto si quieren
pero si lo recuerdan sabrán que esto es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2
así que para encontrar la magnitud del
componente horizontal aunque ahorita en
este momento no voy a usar la
calculadora todavía porque 10 x raíz de
3 entre 2 va a ser igual 10 entre dos es
5 por la raíz cuadrada de 3 metros por
segundo nunca olvidemos las unidades
así que si quiero calcular el
desplazamiento horizontal total vamos a
escribirlo aquí nuestro desplazamiento
horizontal que es lo que significa esto
va a ser igual a la velocidad promedio
en la dirección horizontal y ésta va a
ser este 5 por raíz de 3 metros por
segundo ya que esta velocidad no va a
cambiar esto es igual 5 por raíz de 3
metros por segundo
todo esto multiplicado por el cambio en
el tiempo es decir que tanto tiempo
estuvo en el aire y encontramos que es
de 1.02 segundos así que esto está x
1.02
estos segundos se cancelan con estos
tendremos nuestro resultado en metros y
ahora sí voy a sacar mi calculadora para
hacer las operaciones y tenemos 5 por la
raíz cuadrada de 3 por 1 punto 02 y esto
nos da 8 puntos 83 34 y vamos a
redondear lo a dos lugares decimales
esto es igual a 8 punto 83 metros y con
eso terminamos esta pregunta en el
siguiente vídeo les enseñaré otra manera
para calcular esto para mostrarles que
hay diversas maneras de resolver esta
misma cuestión aunque es un poquito más
complicada también es bastante más
poderosa no serviría por ejemplo para
casos en donde tenemos diferente
elevación de lanzamiento y aterrizaje
del proyectil